okay well welcome back our the second
method of this section is clustering
um which refers to a broad set of
techniques for finding subgroups or
clusters in data
so we're trying to segment or partition
the data into subgroups that are are
similar to each other and of course
we'll have to define what we mean by
similar or different to in order to do
the partitioning and um in a lot of
cases they are in the the way we decide
to cluster the way we we decide on
what's somewhat different depends on the
context so
how does that principle components
analysis which we just discussed how
does it contrast with clustering well
pca as we've seen looks for a low
dimensional representation or view of
the data that explains a good fraction
of the variance right so we saw the pca
plots
and we
we from it we derive new variables which
could be used for other methods like
supervised learning
um clustering on the other hand looks
for homogeneous subgroups of the
observations
okay so it's not not looking for
variance but looking is looking for
similarity among observations
uh for example if we're trying to try
and do a segmentation of a market
suppose for um
each of a number of customers we have we
we've measured things like their income
their occupation
how far they live the closest urban area
and so forth and we want to sub we want
to segment them
or group them
into into uh
customers that are similar with regard
to these features and why do we want to
do that because maybe if they're similar
with regard to these features then the
the the kind of advertising we use for
that subgroup will be
uh important so we use a certain kind of
advertising for one subgroup like maybe
young males
who have a lot of money one subgroup
another subgroup might be like me but uh
yeah
young men
uh okay
uh another group maybe um
housewives who in their 50s who um
you know or their children have grown up
and they're they're either they're they
like to travel for example they may want
to advertise a different way to that
subgroup
so
um
that the task of segmenting that kind of
population is is a
key application of clustering
so we're going to talk about two
clustering methods in this section now
there are lots more as in most areas of
statistics there's a many many ways of
doing things but the two most important
methods which we'll talk about are
k-means clustering
in which we first of all predefine k the
number of clusters and then we have
we'll see there's a way of grouping the
observations into the k groups then of
course you'll have to define what k is
this number of subgroups and that's
going to be important and hard difficult
choice
in the second method is called
hierarchical clustering which we don't
pre-specify the number of clusters k but
rather we do
we group the data in all numbers of
clusters and it's done in a hierarchical
agglomerative fashion
and this is nice because we get to see
the
the clustering for all numbers of
clusters k
but let's start with the simplest method
k means clustering
um before we describe it let's see an
example of of the result of k-means
clustering so this is some simulated
data
and
it's been simulated basically in two
groups
which are
the the upper group there's two features
and there's a
group at the top some space in between
and a group at the bottom
and now
when we apply k-means clustering and we
have to pre-specify k again we'll see
the the procedure in a few slides
but when we press up pre-specify k
equals 2 and we run the clustering
algorithm it produces
the
the groups indicated by the two colors
blue and gold
so with k equals 2 it's found
approximately the right clusters
although you might argue well does this
point actually belong in the upper
cluster rather than the bottom cluster
and that that's not something which you
can answer just in a quantitative way
that's a
subjective call
um
in any case it seems to found the two
clusters
uh pretty pretty correctly but if i were
to have specified k equals three it
would be forced to find three groups
and the three groups k means clustering
found or indicated here by the green the
blue and the gold so what's done is it's
broken up this apparently homogeneous
cluster into two clusters
similarly with k equals four
it finds the blue
the orange
the purple and the green right so it's
it's broken up this bottom cluster looks
like into three clusters although it's
borrowed some points from the top right
there
so you can see that the effect of
k-means clustering well first of all you
can see the effect of k is really
important right because if you use k to
be too large it's going to be forced to
uh to break up groups like this one
which are fairly homogeneous
it's what's also interesting rob is that
variables that are somewhat responsible
for clusters like for example this the
second variable that we have over here
um also tend to have a high variance
because you know if if they separate the
data in in in clusters that this tends
to be variance so so there's some
connection between principal components
and clustering but in the in a more
abstract sense okay so let's actually
drill down into the details of k-means
clustering well first of all we have to
define uh some some notation for for
clusters or sets so we'll call them c1
through ck
and they're sets of of indices of the
observations so the indices are one
through n those are n observations each
of these c's is going to be a subset of
1 through n
okay and this the subset is going to
it's going to be a partition of 1
through n
now as we want to get formalistic we'll
say well the c's their union is 1
through n so if we if we
can count them all together they make up
one through n so they're a partition of
one through n and there's no
intersection so there's no overlap
between the clusters so that's just a
fancy way of saying we're gonna
we're gonna break up the points one
through n into um k groups which are not
overlapping and cover the whole set
okay
and
again if if the ith observation is in
the k-th cluster then i will be a member
of the indices for group k
okay
so
again we want to somehow find a
partition c1 through ck which is a good
clustering what do we mean by good
clustering well k means clustering
defines good clustering to have
to be one in which the within cluster
variation is small
okay
so
let's get back to this picture
if you ask me well divide this into say
two groups well the notion that k-means
is going to use to say well i'm going to
find two groups so that within each
group like within the gold the variation
is smaller than the group so that the
points are close together similarly for
this group the points are close together
it's kind of a very intuitive definition
so
let's call the lynn cluster variation of
the cluster ck
wcv for whim cluster variation of ck is
the total variation okay for example we
could use square distance
in the two directions matter of fact
most of the time we will use square
distance for k-means clustering
so then
well if we put it all together if we
define the the variation within a
cluster to be wcv of ck
we want to find well the total variation
uh adding up over all clusters is here
and we want to find the partitioning c1
through ck to minimize the total within
cluster variation
okay
so we're going to assign the n data
points to k clusters so that the total
within cluster variation
summed up over the k clusters is as
small as possible
so now i said this on a previous slide
but here's in detail
we normally define within cluster
variation to be the euclidean distance
the pairwise square distance between
each pair of observations in the cluster
add it up over the p feature so that
this is the the euclidean or square
distance between observations i and i
prime
and we sum it up over all ii prime in
the cluster so
now this is the total pairwise distance
of every between every pair in the in
the in the clusters ck
and we're going to
minimize the total of this over k the
total variation over all clusters
and that's
here it is so here's our optimization
problem now here's the within cluster
variation
um and we're going to
we're going to
find that the clustering c13 that
minimizes that
so um
we have a criterion but let's actually
uh talk about the k-means algorithm and
then we'll then we'll we'll sort of
circle back and and see why it minimized
the objective on the previous slide
so how k means clustering works well
it's got the word means in it so it's
going to use a mean somehow so it's
actually an alternating algorithm that
first of all we assign
uh to each observation a cluster from
one to k so remember k is fixed we have
to decide ahead of time i'm going to
pick k equals for example two or k
equals three and we'll worry later about
how to choose k an important
value but let's fix k for the moment so
if each observation is assigned to a
cluster run through k
and then we we have two steps which we
alternate back and forth for each of the
k clusters and the ones one hand we
compute the centroid that's the average
value in in for each feature of all the
points in the centroid in the cluster
okay so it's just it's the mean of in
the vertical and horizontal direction
of the points in that in that cluster
so
having computed the centroids for each
of the clusters
on the other step we we do we we assign
each each data point to the closest
centroid
and then having done that
we have
a new set of cluster assignments c1
through ck we go back and compute new
centroids
using the new centroids you complete new
assignments we alternate back and forth
until hopefully this thing settles down
and the solution is the k means
clustering
now the solution we want is the
assignment of points to the to the
groups
so
let me actually
i'm going to show an example well let's
see an example and then we'll go back
and and and and see why that algorithm
actually minimizes the objective that we
wrote down so here's an example um
actually the same example we have before
here's our data okay again it's
unlabeled data right and we've chosen k
equals three
so in the first step we're going to
assign
points at random to clusters so we have
to indicate these by the colors
okay and so each point is assigned to
cluster to
to a different color and you'll see the
assignment is
the grouping is not very good yet in
other words we like we're thinking that
this is one group and this is another
group but we don't we're no we're
nowhere near that clustering at this
point
the first step we compute the centroids
right so that these are the the average
of the horizontal vertical direction of
all of all the points in the gold green
and blue
groups and then here the centroids are
pretty much on top of each other because
the assignment was random so
there's no real grouping yet
but uh
no don't fear the creaminess clustering
will work its way to a good solution so
now
we take the centroids and we
we find the closest points to each of
the centroids so each point is we ask
which point are you closest to the green
the purple or the orange centroid and
now we close the points accordingly so
this is the partitioning step
so even though those first three
centroids were pretty much on top of
each other they weren't exactly and so
that defines a fairly nice partition of
the data already yeah under it's an
almost
well almost perfect job in terms of well
you see we'll get to the final iterate
and then given this new assignment we
we find the the centroids again but now
the centers are going to move a lot now
right because look what the points are
so for example the average of these gold
points is way up here so here's the new
gold centroid new purple new green
now the centroids are sitting really
right in the middles of the clusters
and
the algorithm will now continue and make
a few refinements and here's the final
k-mean solution from this for this
example very intuitive algorithm
so
let's go back remember we have a
subjective function which is the total
within cluster variation we want to
minimize right you want to find the
partitioning
that minimizes this within cluster
variation well the question is have we
does this algorithm that we
wrote down does it achieve that
but we can you can actually see that the
algorithm
will always decrease the value of the
objective at each step
and you might think about why that is
well the key to it really is that
you can write the variation the pairwise
variation
as the variation around the the the uh
component wise means okay
so and this is really the key to k-means
clustering think about it we we really
didn't we didn't care about the
centroids all we cared about was the
clustering well k-means clustering is
done is it's it's it's
it's put in there it's changed this
to an equivalent expression involving
the centroid
and now k-means clustering finds both
the component the the component uh
c130k as well as the centroid centroids
x bar
and
um
what it does at each step is it
minimizes over ck and one hand or
minimizes over the century on the other
hand and each of those steps is going to
decrease this criterion and hence
decrease this criterion
okay so if you have centroids
then
when you when you come to
update the assignment of each point it's
going to go to the the group for which
this distance is smallest for fixed
centroids and on the other hand if if
all the assignments are fixed we know
that the sample mean
is minimizes the sum of squares
and so that's why each of those steps
necessarily makes the criterion go down
so this is this is very slick we started
off with the problem involving one set
of variables we made it we added another
set of variables which
we think can make it harder but actually
makes it easier right because now
because when you do the join
optimization over both sets of variables
we get to the answer for the ones we
care about the clustering
so
that's just the detail of the previous
figure which we talked about
now oh sorry i missed a point here which
is that
it's not this algorithm although gives
you a local minimum it's not guaranteed
to give a global minimum
why not well what does that mean rob a
local minimum local minimum means that
um
well the point is is that they could you
could start the algorithm from
okay the local medium i guess means in
calculus it means that the the
derivative of the function is zero
okay it doesn't mean that it's the
lowest point of the function so if a
function is not convex you can have a
place where the
where the derivative or the valley which
is flat but it's not the lowest value in
the whole function
right so
this algorithm will get to a local
minimum we'll get to a place get to a
valley of the of the the function we're
trying to minimize but it won't be the
lowest value necessarily so we can think
of this this function that we're trying
to optimize as being like a a big valley
but it's got lots of little sub valleys
or little ponds or whatever and
you know any minimum is one of those and
we can get stuck in one of those right
so in the optimization world the idea of
the idea of a convex function which is
basically there's only one valley so if
you find a minimum it's a global minimum
but this function is not convex in other
words it can go up and down and have
more than one valley and the k-means
algorithm will land you in a valley but
not necessarily the lowest valley
because the function's not convex
so
actually here's an example this for the
same did here's an example where we
start the algorithm from
six different starting configurations
remember our starting configuration was
we assigned each point at random to one
of the clusters
and this is actually a good thing to do
with k-means clustering is since we're
not guaranteed to get the global minimum
we start the algorithm at more than one
place and we just examine the value of
the criterion at the end of at the end
in each case remember starting the
algorithm was this random assignment of
points to to the number of clusters
you're using
right so when we start the algorithm
from different places we get actually
quite different solutions don't worry
about the fact that the colors are
chosen
differently like this
these are gold and these are green that
the coloring is arbitrary but the the
partitioning is quite different um
and we typically pick the lowest value
there's let's see
this guy well these looks like we've got
three different solutions there three or
four different three different yeah
three different solutions right i guess
the one the ones who colored in red at
the top all have exactly the same
distance yeah so they're actually all
the same the colorings
are different but as rob said the
colorings are arbitrary yeah so the the
these solutions these four panels give
us the the solution with this but the
top left and the bottom right are
actually different solutions again right
okay so uh that's k-means clustering
we'll actually talk a little bit about
the end how to choose k
or which also be a an issue for
hierarchical clustering which is a topic
of our next in our next segment